I dropped down to the ground and I was
gasping for air
just couldn't could couldn't breathe
couldn't breathe and I was like I I
don't know what's wrong with me what's
wrong with me and it gets worse oh I lay
down and it's like laying down was like
trying to breathe out of a straw when
you're underwater the doctor says you
have a pulmonary embolism a very large
pulmonary embolism we usually find them
but you either find them before you die
or you find them after you die you're
fortunate that we found it before you
died welcome back to LED live in
2025 Happy New Year I am glad to be
alive looks like it literally uh as
we'll get into this story a little bit
uh I really am glad to be alive it's a
weird and strange thing to um to be told
that you were actually almost not going
to wake up in the morning that's so so
bizarre so yeah I hope that you guys had
a blessed year and um you know as you
think about this new
year just praise God for every day that
we have life and I'll tell you what have
you ever been close to death yeah
several times several times yeah several
things happen like how close I almost
got hit by our car ones so I'm from the
Netherlands and in Netherlands as people
know we drive we ride a lot of bicycles
and so it's not like you just go for a
fun right it's your transportation
vehicle yep I was riding to high school
I was a
teenager and uh I was about to cross the
road and everybody stopped at this
intersection and I for some reason
didn't I didn't see anything and there
was this car coming and you were allowed
to drive about I don't know like 35 or
something miles per hour and this car
was like full on just like a race car
coming toward me and I had the gears
right and was in the lowest like the
first gear so your your your pedals are
going really fast but for some reason I
had enough time to look to the left
realize what was happening look forward
and like pedal in my first light gear
and make it across which wouldn't get
you very far normally and I made it and
I was like Wow and I've just become a
Christian I realized God protected me I
I should have been dead I mean everybody
rides bikes right so you just got yeah I
think there's more bikes in the
Netherlands than are people seriously
and I think people drive really fast in
the Netherlands too yeah well I'll tell
you what I had a biking accident as well
and um this uh this past uh holiday
season my son he really wanted to go on
a mountain biking trip and or not a
mountain biking trip a mountain biking
day and he goes um Dad you got to really
try this this uh mountain biking course
we got a lot of awesome courses around
here um one right behind a university
that's real close to our office here and
um he goes dad there's some really big
jumps back there you got to go try this
okay oh boy I'm I'm I'm I used to do
this stuff as a kid yeah so this is not
unusual for me I mountain bike a little
bit um um but I grew up playing lots of
different types of sports and stuff like
that so um you know I'm not an obice at
it basically but I don't go on jumping
courses very often yeah so I throw my
bike in the car take my son out there
he's in front of me and he takes me on
this course and it was like really fun
like lots of little whoop D Woos and
jumps and stuff like that and and it was
great and um made it through it he said
let's do it again so we did it again
wrote it one more time and he goes dad
on the other side of the Hill there's
this other course and it's got some
pretty cool jumps too let's go over
there so we Traverse across this whole
thing and um I think you know there's
good advice always I remember when when
when when you go snowboarding they say
don't try anything crazy on your last
run oh yeah that's this is your last run
don't try anything crazy and I'm getting
like confident you know and I'm just
like okay I'm doing this I'm I'm I'm I'm
getting my wheels off the ground and
stuff like this so my son's in front of
me and he's doing the the trails and I'm
kind of following him and uh on the last
one I was just bombing way too fast way
too hard I overshot The Landing by quite
a bit and as I started to rotate forward
I hit the flat part of the ground and I
didn't even get my hands off the
handlebars I went straight into the
ground and smacked my clavicle pretty
bad busted it in about uh four different
spots and when I popped up you know I
was pretty upset I was like ah come on I
knew I knew something was wrong and I
brought my arm I'm not going to
demonstrate it with this one but I
brought my arm like this all the way
around because I was kind of doing the
self check I had bleed blood kind of
dripping down from my nose and stuff and
so I didn't know what I had broke I
didn't know if I smash my face on the
ground or what and as I as I brought my
arm around like this it was just like
crunch crunch crunch crunch crunch and I
was like you heard it oh yeah and I said
dude I'm really far from the
car like we were at the probably the
furthest point from the car that I could
actually get and I had this one thought
well how are they going to get me down
like if I sit down uh we're going to
have problems so I just picked up my
bike and I go son we got to go and I
just like literally focused on the trail
it was the last jump I had one more to
one jump last jump had I made that last
one I'd be fine today sucks so didn't
have my phone on me or anything like
this so I just started walking out of
these Trails I told my son to um ride up
ahead go get my truck and and uh call
call my wife MH and so by the time I got
back to the truck it was was probably a
good 20 30 minute walk out of there I
was hurting pretty bad oh yeah that
would be painful yeah I was pretty I was
hurting pretty bad I knew I knew I'd
heard some stuff but I didn't want to
freak my son out so
um I just kind of got he didn't know
that you were that you had broken
anything he didn't tell him you know I
told him I told him okay time to go but
I didn't like dwell on it you know what
I mean um so he probably didn't know how
bad it was I just kind of had my arm
down to my side and um and he was just
like are you okay Dad you okay you sure
you don't want me to go get somebody I
was like no we're just we're we're going
out of here well by the time I got back
to the car um some people had met us
there and then okay we're going to the
ER so ended up going to the ER took a
bunch of x-rays I'd busted it in four
different spots pretty much blew it up
and what's crazy is that I didn't even
check your ribs that didn't check
anything cuz your ribs were broken too
well they're like where does it hurt and
I'm like somewhere right around here you
know I could hardly like breathe and of
course when I go to the are there's like
people in there for like you know cut
finger and you know it's like they're
taking their sweet Berry time and then
they just like we're here take this pain
pill and go home seriously I've never
broken a bone before never been to the
ER before um I'm surprised I've made it
this far in life um and uh I think your
wife would be surprised too yeah to be
honest you know I'm I'm I'm I'm 46 years
old there is no reason why my wheels
need to be leaving the ground at this
point no reason I mean when I found out
I'm like yeah I'm I'm not surprised you
know what I mean and it's like had I
just gone on the course and like you
know kind of went over all the jumps and
stuff like that first saw the landing so
I hit this jump not seeing the bottom
side of the landing so big big big
regret there but anyway um they send me
home I ended up getting an orthopedic
surgeon they um about a week later I had
to have reconstructive surgery and they
put a plate with a bunch of screws in it
and like this so now every time you go
through the metal detector it's
like right right right I fly a little
bit so it's going to be a problem right
this is not the problem if I was to
break a bone um and since I've never
really broken very many bones I've
broken ribs before dirt biking and
things like that but but there's not
much that they can do about it they
can't cast it or anything like that um
the clavicle actually was a really good
option to break mhm um I could have torn
my shoulder off I I I didn't get my
hands out I could have RI broken my arms
I didn't get my face directly in the
ground I could have smashed up my face
broke my nose or whatever right I got
broke your neck broke my neck I mean it
could have been really bad I I was I was
flying and and um so I I felt like okay
I really got away from this thing pretty
lucky comparatively thinking you know um
so surgery went great picked a great
orthopedic surgeon put me back together
and they said send me home well I'm on
pain pills so I don't feel much MH you
know I mean I'm I'm actually surprised
like man I feel great day after surgery
I literally was ready to come back into
work and you know I popped up in the
morning I was making waffles my wife was
just like dude what are you doing you
just had surgery I was like I feel great
I'm going to work and she was like sit
down I was like okay she's like you're
on pain pills like you don't feel what
you probably do feel and you just need
to relax you had surgery don't move your
arm and you know just just just take it
easy so that's hard for me I'm I'm kind
of an active person so anyway for the
week I go you know my brother brought me
a a recliner chair and I sleep upright
in a chair so for about a week and a
half now about a week and a half to two
weeks have gone by since the
accident and um I'm just running out of
pain pills and uh I have one left and my
wife just for whatever her intuition was
she she was just like don't take that
last pain pill like just just you know
start to begin to feel what you're
feeling so you can kind of understand
what you're working with here and so I
kind of let it run out and um we had
some friends over Keith was over and
stuff and I was feeling great up walking
around and and and talking and
everything and when he left I was like
you know I'm kind of feeling a little
bit like really around my rib areas my
back starting to hurt and so I sit on
the couch and I tell my wife I say can
you get out the massage gun and just
kind of work on these parts because I
know I'm bruised up um just kind of work
lightly on these things like this and
she's just massaging my back I'm kind of
leaning into it I'm like yeah yeah that
feels great oh yeah you know turn that
thing up a notch you know and and and
get it
going and then all of a sudden it was
like about 15 minutes of this the pain
pills were really starting to wear off
at this point my body just went Scott I
need you to feel what you're doing to
your
body all the muscles around my rib cage
and everything just immediately seized
up locked up and I couldn't take a
breath oh I dropped down to the ground
and I was gasping for air
just couldn't could couldn't breathe
couldn't breathe
I was like I I don't know what's wrong
with me what's wrong with me and then
you freak out and it's even worse you
can't even panic mode yeah yeah right
there I should have gone in the car and
went to the ER that's what I should have
done but I'm thinking like well how how
much is that going to cost me right so
I'm like don't worry I'll just go
upstairs and I'm just going to lay on
the bed and and I'll be fine just bring
me a heat pad so I have my wife heat up
a heat pad I lay down which is one of
the worst things you could possibly do
at this point mhm and it gets worse oh I
lay down and it's like laying down was
like trying to breathe out of a straw
when you're underwater dude and it was
just like I can't I can't can't get a
breath I can't get enough oxygen so
scary that is so scary so I finally calm
down and I'm thinking okay I must have
hurt something they didn't tell me I
broke anything else but but I I know at
this point I must have hurt something
and having my M my wife do the massage
gun um obviously I'm hurting my
ribs so uh I I'm laying down and I go
okay I just need to calm down I just
need to go to bed I go to bed I wake up
in the morning to my wife putting a um
pulse
soomets your oxygen
levels and when the reading comes up for
the the um the the little pulse oxom it
says
70% yikes do you know how low that is I
I don't I'm not a okay that that
actually can start shutting down your
organs you what
yeah that's not good and if I've been at
70% all night long that's actually
really really really bad dud so of
course naturally my wife pops up we are
going to the ER right now and I'm like
no no no I'll be fine I'll be fine I
just I can't take a deep breath so I'm
thinking like I hurt my ribs I hurt
myself I can't breathe because I can't
take a deep breath I'm not getting the
oxygen that I need to get and let me
just calm down I'll take I'll stand up
and I'll take a few brief she's just
like starting to well up Tears In Her
Eyes she's like get in the car right now
I don't want to take I don't want to
listen to any excuse that you have and
you know like when you're you're a wife
there's like this intuition that you
have where you're just like I'm not
playing around you get in the car right
now we're not we're not going to discuss
this this is not open for discussion
yeah so reluctantly get in the car we go
down to the ER it's an absolute
zoo and um I get to uh fill out all the
paperwork and you know it's like they
get you know by the time they call me um
back there one of the first things that
they want to do to me is put me in the
CT scanner and just see what's really
going on in my body MH so I get in the
wheelchair they drive me back and the
guy lays me down on the CT scanner and I
immediately feel like I can't grab a
breath I it felt like someone had dunked
my head underwater and was holding me
underwater and I'm trying trying to like
lift my head up and get a breath and I'm
starting to panic and I'm like I can't
breathe I can't breathe I can't breathe
and it's like literally pain shooting
all over my body and they're like calm
down calm down like the nurse comes
running over and I'm like I can't
breathe and they calm me down I get my
breath just enough and they're like okay
we're going to do this quickly and they
just I just we just have to take the CT
scan so they put my arm up and um I can
barely put my arm up I haven't felt pain
like this in a long time which one is
that one no
this one I know is all busted up and
it's all from the surgery and stuff like
this my arm's not broken but but but I
don't want to move it because of this so
so they just made me move this
one so they run me through the CT
scanner and immediately when they put me
back in the um the wheelchair and
they're Wheeling me back out my wife's
out in the in the waiting room um I just
start crying I mean I just had this
emotional release of this just like that
was the most panicking helpless feeling
i f in a long time and there was nothing
I could do about it and and it was just
it was an awful feeling so I get out
there my wife's just like you know I'm
getting wheeled back with tears in my
eyes and and she's just like are you
okay like what they do to you and so I
explain to her what happened then the
doctor comes out and he says okay please
both of you come with me I'm going to
put you in a room back there and when
they say that kind of a thing you know
like okay what what what what happened
yeah you think the worst you know yeah I
know I broke some stuff but am I
internally bleeding inside like what's
going on mhm the doctor says you have a
pulmonary embolism a very large
pulmonary embolism in the little V valve
that comes off of your heart that sends
the blood through your heart to your
left and your right lung to pick up
oxygen you're a you're a big portion of
that
[Music]
blocked when you hear something like
that it's just just like but this was
the problem you know what I mean like
like this is what I feel what does that
mean and they're like well here's what
it is with pulmonary
embolisms we usually find them but you
either find them before you die or you
find them after you
die you're fortunate that we found it
before you
died and I think about this and I go you
know my wife had this intuition don't
take that last pain pill had I taken
that maybe I would have masked this
whole thing had I not had her work on my
ribs I went upstairs I went home and
went to sleep and they said last night
literally could have been your last
night that's so bizarre dude you could
have woken up and like I I just can't
imagine your wife waking up next to you
and like you're You're gone yeah so
bizarre I I I I went to bed that night
and then it would have been like Jesus
is coming yeah second coming I'll tell
you what I've done a lot of thinking
since that
night and of course you know they they
um they've taken care of it since then
put me on blood thinners and and and
things like that and um I think with my
current situation they say that the the
the the chances are pretty good you know
they put you on blood thinners for quite
a while so they say don't climb up a
ladder and fall off a ladder because if
you cut yourself or you you know you
have a problem it's it it's going to be
difficult to stop the bleeding
but I I I I still go back to that like
what if you didn't wake up
MH are you ready to
die I I I mean that with all sincerity
yeah like that thought was like what
you've said you've said what you've done
you've done the way you've lived your
life you've lived your life you get zero
point from from this point forward to
make any further decision about anything
I think I think that's the thing that um
that a lot of people who are healthy who
live a prosperous life don't think about
that it's
like if you read
Revelation what is it three two and
three you read about this the seven
churches and various Scholars from
various denominations see this as both
historically in Paul's time there were
those seven churches but also that they
were time periods of the God's Church in
the future right um and we are currently
in the last church it was the historical
church of leod DEA but also they they
were considered a lukewarm church we are
considered the lukewarm church we can't
get around that God is saying it and I
agree with it and I think that a lot of
us as Christians think well I'm healthy
and I'm this and I'm that and I'm just
living a lukewarm Christian Life it's
like I'm not really sold out to Christ
I'm not really in the world and kind of
in the middle but it's like with you
like at any moment you can die like I
could be hit by a car driving home today
and my fate is sealed you can't just say
well um whatever like um I'll have
another day to live and then I can fully
come to
Jesus and then we go back to that
question of like once saved always saved
is that biblical no it's not there's too
many verses in the Bible that indicate
that not everybody who calls on the name
of Jesus will be saved there's going to
be two groups of people that there going
to be people saying Lord Lord have I not
prophesied in your name have I not done
all of these things in your name cast
out demons demons done wonderful Works
dude that that's like doing all the
things but go Jesus is like I don't know
you right so and we can go deeper into
that there's um we do actually have
another podcast that's audio only at
that I host and we actually talk to
someone about the idea of once safe
always safe we'll put a link in the
description for you toist listen to this
because I know a lot of people believe
in this concept but please um look into
this you know look look look into this
concept of one saved all saved and why
that's actually uh a way to La
Christians to sleep and not be totally
sold out to Jesus but think about it
right I'm reading I like reading the
stories the magazines from voice of the
martyrs and there's people who are like
doing the work in all these third world
countries with Muslims attacking their
Villages burning down their Villages who
are like I will die sharing the Gospel
of
Jesus rather than whatever like they're
willing to die are we are we willing to
die yeah right and and and like at any
moment your fate can be sealed what ises
your relationship with Jesus really like
are do you really believe if you look at
your own life
not talking about salvation by work
salvation happens through faith by
through Jesus alone amen but are you
truly sold out to Jesus by the your
fruits you shall know them by your
fruits in your life are you showing I'm
totally sold out to Jesus he's number
one in my life or do you have all these
other gods in your life it could be
anything that you put in front of God
anything
today today if you haven't made that
decision today look I I I lived my life
for many years in my early 20s on the
edge doing stupid things that literally
I probably could have died a number of
times you know and and and that would
have been it my my fate would have been
sealed I've chosen to give my heart to
God I I I I work in Ministry um you know
if if my life were to end
tonight and and and that was it I would
say like Paul look I ran the race I kept
the faith I haven't released that mhm
but this this this this was something
that really confronted me am I ready to
die right now yeah like am I really
ready yeah it's one thing to talk about
that it's one thing to say that I came
close to that I I'm lucky to be here
right now and the point of this is is
it's like you know do I really need to
do things like flying my bike through
the air at age 46 years old getting as
much air as I can on some sort of
tabletop jump is that really
smart yeah oh I mean do I need to be
doing that not to say like okay I I
wasn't I wasn't fearful that I would die
right there but a chain of events right
now could have easily ended my
life I hope and
pray that my life is different from this
point
forward I you know I kind of feel a bit
like um King
Hezekiah mhm yeah if I was told that I
had 15 years left to live how would that
change your life and you know we are
living if you look at the Statue of uh I
think it's Daniel 2 we are living in the
tippy toes yeah it's obvious we living
at the end of the time yeah look at the
world around you it's coming apart like
Matthew 24 to the times yeah and then I
think God is saying to us like how many
more signs am I supposed to give you to
wake you up up right how many more signs
do you need to let you know I'm coming
soon and I want to take you with me
right but you're not letting me work in
your heart that's right that's right you
know I I worked at a different Ministry
before this for many years and I've told
you this story before I don't think I
would have made it I don't think I would
have made not the ministry's fault my
heart wasn't ready I worked full-time in
Ministry but at home I was addicted to
YouTube I was addicted to whatever
stuff was out there Media stuff that was
my God in my life that I put before God
I woke up I barely had devotions with
the Lord I barely talked to him during
the day but I went to church every
single weekend I went to church I
everybody in the outside thought I look
great I was involved in fulltime
Ministry was involved in Church
Ministries but my heart was not ready
and I tell you now if that Mark of the
Beast would have come
then I would have I I would have
probably taken it not because I'm just
like oh yeah I'm going to do it because
the pressure because I did not have a
genuine honest real connection with
Jesus to the point where I would have
said
Lord I will worship you though the
heavens may fall they may kill me they
may torture me I will follow you I did
not have that and that's the The
Epiphany the wording of the Le Dean
church is you are lukewarm and if you
stay lukewarm you will turn cold yeah
unless you seek Jesus with all of your
heart today when you hear this God only
through his grace can help you to turn
hot for him that we like those people
those Martyrs overseas in other
countries are like I'm not going to deny
my Lord I love him so much how could I
amen look a lot of people make a lot of
promises in the New Year it's obviously
a new year mhm we're one year closer to
Jesus I love it I love it when I when I
hear people say that but really honestly
we are one year closer what if this
thing is I mean Jesus is right at the
door 2025 I'm not saying anything but I
know there's a lot of stuff happening in
2025 watch our videos make your decision
for Jesus today mhm listen to some of
these Bible verses mhm 2 Corinthians 6:2
for he says in a favorable time I listen
to you and in the day of salvation I
have helped you behold now is the
favorable time behold now is the day of
salvation choose you to stay whom you
will serve today choose it now you don't
know if you're going to have tomorrow I
mean I I've always like romanticized
after working in ministry right we're
going to go I hope I'm going out with
like literally truth guns blazing all
the way to the end I want to I want to I
want to go to the end and if I die I
want to die in some way that it's like
look a lot of people around me are going
to heaven because of something that I
was engaged in not that I went mountain
biking and smash my face on the ground
you know what I
mean you don't know though you you you
don't know what your end is going to be
today is the day of salvation look if
you have chosen today brothers and
sisters I want to tell you today choose
today you don't know if you got tomorrow
listen to this verse Hebrews 3:7 and8
therefore as the holy spirit says today
if you hear his voice do not Harden your
hearts as in the Rebellion on the day of
the testing in the wilderness we're all
going to be
tested there's there going to be some
point and this Mark of the Beast test
issue is want to touch every single
person on the face of the planet do you
have the Seal of God or do you have the
mark of the beast and also this where
talks about detesting in the wilderness
it's referring to the Israelites going
through the Wilderness before they made
the promised land this is a symbol of
what we're going through we are in the
wilderness on our way to the spiritual
Canaan the promised land and it's like
today if you hear his voice do not
Harden your hearts as in the Rebellion
stop your Rebellion come to Jesus
brothers and sisters today please it's a
new year but today don't just make this
decision just because it's a new year
just today whenever you're listening to
this message today if you hear the voice
of God make that choice for him Psalms
957 and8 says for he is our God and we
are the people of his pasture and the
Sheep of his hand today if you hear his
voice do not Harden your hearts as in
marah as in the day of Mana Massa in the
wilderness
do you see the urgency throughout the
history of time Jesus loves us so much
and he's just crying out for us he's
like please what are you waiting for I'm
here you know like oh it must break his
heart to see our Leo deene lukewarm
condition one thing that you can do that
you can basically say okay if I actually
thought that this was my last year on
the planet I was given a terminal
illness and I knew at the end of this
year my life is going to be over how
would that actually impact or change
your life what would that actually do to
the decisions you're making what makes
that important is the strive for you
know as much money as you humanly can
make as possible is that what's
important what would make that important
if you really said I only got this year
dude I think you would give everything
to your family to your relationship with
God you know what I mean so but but I
think that's why God doesn't set a time
from when he comes back because it's
easier to do it that way but God's like
I just want a genuine real relationship
with you yep and when you don't have a
time that's when he's coming back and
you are sold out to him man what a
testimony that is to the love of God yep
listen to this final verse here I love
this verse Acts 16:31 and they said to
him believe in the Lord Jesus Christ and
you will be saved you and your household
Paul and Silas isn't that beautiful you
in your household I mean what a what
because the faith of Noah his family was
saved so you know we can have a huge
impact even onto our own household and
they all believed every single one
person in this story believed exactly
and but what a beautiful promise um you
know as you guys start out this new
year give God a chance today mhm I mean
if you've not given him your full heart
your full mind your full everything
dedicate your your life to him all it
takes right now is starting by just
going God I'm Yours what do you want for
me what do you want to do I didn't know
I wanted to work in Ministry I didn't
have a Ministry minded plan I worked in
Hollywood and I made the decision to
follow God literally up runion Canyon
underneath the Hollywood sign I
literally said at this point God what do
you want me to do for you and I've been
blessed to have worked in Ministry for
the last 15 years serving God with all
my heart but I'll tell you what there's
still more that I can give to God
there's still that daily connection that
daily surrender that give him my all is
he's in the process of sanctification he
wants to sanctify cleanse us completely
from the inside out so you got to
surrender to let let him do that that's
right I'm praising God that I got
another opportunity and another chance I
know some people are not that lucky but
it's really made me think about my daily
activities my daily surrendering to God
and so thank you for watching LED live
if you haven't seen our work or first
time with this channel check out some of
our other videos like subscribe to this
Channel and we got a lot of cool stuff
coming out but um as always keep us in
your prayers and let's take as many
people to Heaven as we possibly can
let's depopulate hell that's right
[Music]